[Applause]
[Music]
you just have to be at the right range
[Music]
oh
it's going to play in the saints mind a
little bit trying to go for the
backwards orbital but the float from
saints so
good yeah that's that's what one stance
one actually gets you
here we go and [ __ ] final match he got
him with the last hit of the two one two
man but first off like that's
[Music]
what can i do
[Music]
oh
[Music]
sinner with the way he stole that round
insane here we go
nice downpour two there from saint and
if saint finds out that like you're
doing
the reset that was a reset
oh my god big damage on the wall splash
should be the
round yeah and that's what we noticed he
gets it again
don't miss out this time oh saint
is gonna punish him for the mistake and
win the set
[Music]
yeah the wall was closer than you've got
great low parry there from saint though
gonna be a lot of damage saints gonna
have a huge live lead right now
the confirmation he should be able to
end in here
what
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
food